but
speaking of uh apes with egos
some of the most compelling apes two
compelling apes i can think of as
yourself and jordan peterson and you've
had
fun conversation about religion that i
watched
most of i believe i'm not sure there was
any
um uh we didn't solve anything
if anything was ever solved so is there
something uh
like a charitable summary you can give
to the ideas
of that you agree on and disagree with
jordan is there something maybe after
that conversation that you've landed
where maybe uh
as as you both agreed on is there some
wisdom in the rubble
uh even of even um imperfect flawed
ideas
is there something that you can kind of
pull out from those conversations
or is it to be continued i mean i think
where we disagree
so he thinks
that many of our traditional
religious beliefs and frameworks are
uh holding so much such a
a repository of human wisdom
that we we
pull at that fabric at our peril right
like
if you start just unraveling
christianity or any other
traditional set of norms and and beliefs
you you may think you're just pulling
out the unscientific bits
but you could be pulling a lot more to
which
everything you care about is attached
right as a society
and my feeling is that there's so much
there's so much downside to the
unscientific bits and it's so
clear how we could have a
21st century rational conversation about
the good stuff
that we really can radically edit these
traditions and we can take
we can take jesus uh you know in
in half his moods and he just find a
great
inspirational you know you know thought
iron age thought leader you know who
just happened to get crucified but
he could be somewhat like you know the
beatitudes and uh
the golden rule which doesn't originate
originate with him but which
you know he put quite beautifully um
all of that's incredibly useful it's no
less useful than it was two thousand
years ago
but we don't have to believe he was born
of a virgin or coming back to
raise the dead or any of that other
stuff and we can be honest about
not believing those things and we can be
honest about the reasons why we don't
believe those things
because i i on those fronts i view
the downside to be so obvious and the
these
the fact that we have so many different
competing dogmatisms on offer to be so
non-functional i mean it's so divisive
uh it's it just has
conflict built into it that i think we
can be
far more and should be far more
iconoclastic than
he wants to be right now none of this is
to deny
much of what he uh argues for that
that stories are very powerful i mean
clearly stories are powerful and we want
good stories we want our lives we want
to have a conversation with ourselves
and with one another
about our lives that facilitates
the best possible lives and story is
part of that
right and if you want some of those
stories to
to s sound like myths that might be part
of it
right but my argument is that we never
really
need to deceive ourselves or our
children
about what we have every reason to
believe is true
in order to get at the good stuff in
order to organize our lives well you
know i certainly don't feel that i need
to do it personally
and if i don't need to do it personally
why would i think that
billions of other people need to do it
personally right now
there's a there is a cynical counter
argument which is
billions of other people don't have the
advantages that i have had in my life
you know the billions of other people
are not as well educated they haven't
had the same opportunities they have
they they need to be told
that jesus is going to solve all their
problems
after they die say or that uh
you know everything happens for a reason
and you know just your
if you just believe in the secret if you
just visualize what you want you're
gonna get it you know and and
it's like there's some some
some measure of what i consider to be
odious pamblum
that really is food for the better part
of humanity and
and there is no substitute for it or
there's no substitute now
and i don't know if jordan would agree
with that but he much of what he says
seems to
suggest that he would agree with it um
and i guess that's an empirical question
i mean that's just that
we don't know whether given a different
set of norms and a different set of
stories
people would behave the way i would hope
they would behave and
and be aligned you know more line than
they are now i think we know
what happens when you just let
ancient religious certainties go
uncriticized we know what that world's
like
we've lit we we've been struggling to
get out of that world for
a couple hundred years but we know what
you know
having europe uh
riven by religious wars looks like right
and we know what happens when those
religion when those religions become
kind of
pseudo-religions and political religions
right so this is this is where
i'm sure jordan and i would debate he
would say that that you know
stalin was a symptom of atheism and
that's not at all i mean it's not my
kind of atheism right like
stalin the the problem with with the
gulag
and and the experiment with communism or
with stalinism
uh or with nazism was not that
there was so much scientific rigor and
self-criticism and honesty
and introspection and
you know judicious use of psychedelics i
mean
like that was not the problem in
hitler's germany
uh or in stalin's soviet union um
the problem was you have other ideas
that capture a similar kind of
mob based dogmatic energy
and you know yes that's the the results
of all of that are
are predictably murderous well the
question is
what is the source of the most
viral and sticky stories that ultimately
lead to a positive outcome
so communism was i mean having grown up
in the soviet union
even still you know having relatives
in in russia there's a stickiness to the
nationalism and to the
ideologies of communism that religious
or not
you could say it's religious for forever
i could just say it's
it's a viral it's great it's stories
that are viral and sticky
i don't know i'm using the the most
horrible words but the question is
whether
science and reason can generate viral
sticky stories that give meaning to
people's lives
that's yeah it's in your senses it does
well whatever is true ultimately
should be captivating right it's like
what what's more
captivating than what is whatever is
real
right now it it's because reality is
again we're we're so we're just climbing
out of the darkness
you know in terms of our understanding
of what the hell is going on
you